The specific objectives of this lesson are for
you to learn about how we can detect features in an image.
We will specifically be looking at edges in a image and why are edges
important and how they represent the information that's available in an image.
We would look at those within the context of how we can compute image
gradients and how we can actually use the computation of image gradients to
support computation of edges.
I will also give you a little bit of an, a background on how we
can actually compute those image gradients, in a mathematical form for
both doing continuous functions and also discreet forms of images